it's at night that you really get to see
how critical the refugee crisis has
become
a two-month-old baby is amongst the
latest arrivals at the central train
station
they all need somewhere to sleep
inside volunteers are linking up
refugees with polish people offering to
house them it's a chaotic hand-to-mouth
operation but warsaw is already full
explosion
fighting
rockets vladimir and his wife and three
children have been traveling from
kharkiv for three days
the children are completely exhausted
[Music]
and so is the dog
have you found anywhere for your family
to sleep tonight no
really no no
no we
we need it very much
with no other options a volunteer offers
to take them in at the end of her shift
tragic for me
well there are hundreds of people the
organization is very poor here and it
all it works only thanks to volunteers
like myself
then relief as they're told a flat has
been found the family can start to move
on
the best
is
is ahead the best is ahead always
but helping this group of roma
ukrainians is more complex
they're also waiting to be housed and
it's getting late
young faces oblivious to the fact
they've just escaped from a war zone
this family of 47 have just arrived i've
tried to counter children but frankly
lost can't a volunteer told me it
includes 35 children 11 women and one
man the volunteers are trying to find
them somewhere to stay but the problem
is they insist on staying together
there's been an outpouring of generosity
but an inevitable dark side is emerging
to this crisis
with so many women and children on the
move posters have gone up warning
refugees to be on their guard
as we film two men approach the group
there's no obvious reason why they need
to talk to the children making
volunteers suspicious of their motives
of course there is a danger that someone
with speaking bad intentions will
try to
to use the situation
the night wears on and people begin
bedding down with nowhere else to go
outside the refugees just keep on coming
i don't understand
one man
made the trouble at once svetlana turns
to her mother lydia who was born in 1945
when world war ii ended
mom don't know what is it war
now mama have a war
no one wants history to repeat itself
least of all a 77 year old woman now in
poland as a refugee
lisa holland sky news warsaw